Livingston on the pass gets inside shot
won't go but a foul and Kawhi Leonard
gonna come back in the game along with
Kyle Lowry and Van Vleet is on the floor
bleeding his right eye looks like
[Applause]
and the medical team quickly runs out to
check on vanvleet
[Applause]
there you see that left elbow right
smack into the face of an bleep he has
played so well he's so tough and so
valuable you've been one of the great
stories throughout these playoffs
undrafted out of college great career at
Wichita State down to the final four for
Mike they've really shaken up I'm sorry
for cutting you off they're gonna take a
look at that play he was just coming
down yeah but but I do believe this rest
is good for Golden State they were
wobbly Curry's played the whole half
they just looked exhausted they're not
back in transition
I can tell whether shooting they've
missed 13 of their last 15 shots from
the field and Lee gets a nice ovation
the good thing is he's walking off on
his own looked like maybe going back to
check on a foot not wobbling going back
which is the concern when you take a hit
like that to the head they're gonna
probably just stitch him up I didn't
want to play a doctor that is the direct
hit
[Applause]
while he's shaken up
[Applause]
why he's played though they need him
he's been valuable timely baskets but
more importantly defending Steph Curry
this entire series so Mike Callahan now
over at the scorer's table
and just looking at the reply but don't
see how any way they can rule that as a
flagrant here's Alex McKechnie the
director of sports science who's in such
an unbelievable job with Kawhi Leonard
this year leading the way for
[Applause]
white-haired man who was ahead of
VanFleet guys Fred vanvleet will be out
momentarily he did receive seven
stitches he does not have a concussion
they expect him to come back to the
floor and enter the game pretty soon
Kyle Lowry has been spectacular gets the
matchup he likes lols Bogut to sleep
keeps him on his hip and finishes and
how about the young fella Van Vleet
excited about the job his team